$19.27.
[music]
That's the 12-day API bill one developer
posted [music] after pushing 2.1 billion
tokens through Deep Seek's newest model
V4 Flash. Tokens are [music] the
word-size chunks AI companies bill by,
and at Claude Opus' rates, 2 billion of
them would have cost four figures. The
same week this model shipped on July
31st, OpenAI cut its own API prices
[music] by 80%. Deep Seek is dragging
the price of intelligence through the
floor, and we'll tell you how they're
pulling it off.
Every time a model writes a word, it
looks back at everything [music] in the
conversation and scores every earlier
word for how much it should matter right
now. That lookup is called attention,
and there are ugly costs involved.
Double the prompt, and the work
quadruples because every word gets
compared against every other word.
Reading a million token prompt means
roughly half a trillion word pair
comparisons [music]
before the first word of the answer
appears, and the model repeats that
exercise [music] dozens of times
internally. Then, every word it writes
back means consulting that entire
history again. There's a memory bill on
top. To avoid rereading [music] from
scratch, the model keeps working notes
on every word it has seen, and at a
million tokens, those notes outgrow the
memory of a top-end server GPU. Fewer
customers fit on each machine, so every
customer costs more. Providers pass that
straight through. Gemini 3.1 Pro [music]
charges $2 per million input tokens
until your prompt crosses 200,000,
then four, with output jumping from $12
to 18. Most of that work returns
nothing. Measure where attention lands
[music] in a real model, and a handful
of earlier words soak up nearly all the
weight while the rest sit near zero.
>> [music]
>> The model does a stadium's worth of math
to find the three rows that matter.
[music]
Sparse attention is a bet that you can
predict those rows cheaply and spend the
expensive math only there.
Two things kill the bet. If the
predictor is costly, you burn the
savings deciding [music] what to skip.
If it's wrong, the model misses the one
line that mattered and [music] answers
without it as if nothing were missing.
Older short cuts dodge the first problem
with fixed rules, like only reading the
recent past, which is cheap and blind.
The function you defined at the top of
the file stops existing. Pruning bolted
onto a finished model failed, too,
because a model that grew up seeing
everything falls over when you take
[music] most of it away. The unlock, and
the reason this works at frontier scale
now, is training the model with the
skipping from day one, so it learns to
leave behind notes it can skim later.
The design DeepSeek published in its
[music] V4 paper in April runs three
views of your prompt at once. View one
is summaries. Every four tokens of
history gets squashed into one learned
summary entry, like keeping a one-line
description [music] of every function in
a code base. View two is selection. A
tiny scorer called the lightning
indexer, cheap enough to sweep the
entire history, ranks those summaries
against the words [music] being written.
And the 512 best get the full expensive
attention treatment. [music]
View three is the safety net. A second
set of summaries squashes 128 tokens
into one [music] entry each. And the
model reads all of those every time, a
rough table of contents of the whole
[music] prompt, so nothing is ever
completely invisible. The most recent
128 tokens stay uncompressed because the
sentence being finished needs exact
detail. DeepSeek calls the first two
views compressed [music] sparse
attention, and the skim lane heavily
compressed attention. Send 10,000 tokens
or send a million, and the expensive
part of attention now reads roughly the
same small pile. At a million tokens,
DeepSeek's paper claims a tenth of the
attention math and 7% of the attention
memory of its own previous [music]
generation. Those are DeepSeek's
numbers, but the design is public, and
outside teams have already rebuilt
[music] it in the major open-source
serving engines. The research behind
this went public in February 2025 as a
paper called Native Sparse Attention,
[music] which went on to win a best
paper award. The reception was
suspicion. One commenter called an
11-time speedup with no quality loss
almost [music] too good to be true, and
said adoption in the next 6 months would
tell the truth. We're well past this
deadline. [music] The verdict came back
as seven straight weeks as the most used
model on openrouter. Developers posting
invoices like our opener, and [music] a
team running production voice
transcription QA on it at 2 to 5% of
frontier cost. It did take [music] some
tinkering to get to those numbers,
though.
Skipping is what makes each additional
token cheap. Each token starts out cheap
because [music] of the stack underneath.
V4 Flash carries 284 billion parameters,
but wakes about 13 billion per token.
The mixture of experts set [music] up
we're covering in its own video. Much of
the model ships in 4-bit numbers, a
fraction of the usual size, and a small
draft model [music] guesses several
tokens ahead, so the big one can check
instead of write. Stack it up, and
there's your economic gains. 14 cents
per million input tokens, 28 cents per
million out. And if the [music] servers
have seen the start of your prompt
before, cached input drops to a fraction
of a cent. A full million token request
runs about 14 cents. The same request
costs 40 [music] cents on GPT 5.6 Luna's
long context tier, about $2 on Claude
Sonnet 5, over 4 on Gemini 3.1 Pro.
OpenAI's 80% cut [music] landed the day
before this release, and DeepSeek had
already cut its own Pro model by 75% in
May without giving a reason. Prices in
this market are falling faster than the
hardware underneath them got cheaper.
When a scorer misses, nothing crashes.
If the indexer never surfaces a line,
the model doesn't know it existed and
answers fluently from what it did see.
And independent testing finds this model
rarely admits it doesn't know. The
workloads [music] at risk are the ones
where the answer is spread across
everything instead of sitting [music]
somewhere findable. Total every invoice
in a 500-page bundle. Find every clause
that conflicts with a policy. Skip three
entries and the sum arrives wrong
>> [music]
>> with confidence. Compression adds a
second tax. A summary can blur exact
strings, and [music] code, IDs, and
legal text live on exact strings. Two
more honest numbers. Under roughly 10 to
20,000 tokens, the scorer is pure
overhead. Independent profiling of the
previous generation found it slower than
plain attention there. So, the trade
only pays at length. And on DeepSeek's
own million token retrieval tests,
Claude Opus still wins comfortably with
accuracy holding to around 128,000
tokens before it starts [music]
degrading. It's definitely cheap, but
pick the right battles for it.
Long context stops being a luxury good.
Keeping a whole repo, its dogs, and
[music] a week of logs attached to a
session was a $200 habit at Big Lab
prices.
>> [music]
>> Over a stable cached corpus, Deep Seek's
arithmetic works out near 40 cents for
100 turns.
>> [music]
>> Retrieval pipeline survived, demoted
from cost necessity to a speed and
accuracy tool. [music] And watch what
the price does to people. The developer
with $19 bill admits most of his 2
billion [music] tokens were throwaway
experimental loops left running because
the waste cost nothing. When
intelligence gets too cheap to meter,
you stop rationing it. You leave the
whole code base in context and let the
loop run overnight. Every provider you
pay is now pricing its next rate card
against that. I'm looking at you [music]
next, Anthropic.